I have it all figured out  it's an 18-hour trip which breaks down  into six shifts of three hours each or  alternatively we can break it down by  mileage there will be no fart games  while I'm in the car  got it when you're sitting in your Chevy  and you're sure you're feeling heavy  diarrhea diarrhea honey where'd you  learn that song listen to the radio  listen who needs a radio ready Harry  coming up front we're crossing the city  line come on  the cardigan but thanks for noticing  fellas were going a little fast back  there once you say you have any idea how  fast you were going yes you know you  would know better than us especially  since we got a melted speedometer you  see your license  major Robert like what license